um well I shouldn't say this where we
are the first people to come to Camp
here we came on the 27th of April 2023.
how long does it take you to take off
bring all this down some that about
maybe eight hours this is our beds here
this is our food this is our
um how we sleep and this is how we're
living in luxury in Buck's Hotel I'll
see for my own eyes a coronation I'm
gonna ask you they're both wearing
crowns that's my most important moment
with the correlation it's very rare
isn't it that you you're going to live
through and see a coronation
um
and there's not many people alive who
have are going to be living through two
um and it's just going to be wonderful
to watch it I mean it's only something
you can dream up as a royal fan that
atmosphere the camaraderie with people
and it's just going to be magical there
is a sense of humility it is it really
is it's just sort of we all love the
same thing and we just live and
breathing